legue of Legends ranked is saved
potentially this week a rioter shared on
Reddit some very tentative plans to
implement a new rating system for the
game designed by Microsoft called true
skill 2 now some people think it's going
to save everything others think it will
be a total disaster but many people seem
to have got the wrong idea about what it
actually is so let's clear all of that
up
the League of Legends ranked experience
is often described as the worst part of
the entire game and complaints about it
seem to ball down to the same few issues
players don't feel it correctly measures
their skill that too many games feel
like coin flips depending on your
teammates and that once you start losing
more LP for a loss than you gain for a
win you'll essentially be stuck where
you are forever last week there was a
thread on League subreddit complaining
about new accounts being placed too high
in ranked nothing new there but on
Tuesday this week Riot iscar jumped in
the replies to share that Riot is
planning to move to a new rank system
entirely in the near future he said
they'd then be moving to a new system
later in the year called true skill 2
and everyone has pretty much lost their
at this so what exactly is true
skill 2 well there's a 24-page document
on Microsoft's website that explains it
all with painstaking detail which you
should check out if you love complex
equations but here's the more simple
rundown it's an advanced skill rating
system developed by Microsoft and as you
might expect from the two in the name
it's not their first attempt they
developed the original true skill
ranking system way back in 2005 for Xbox
Live for games ranging from Halo 3 to
Forza Motorsport as a way to assess a
player's skill and accurately place them
on rank ladders true skill 2 was
eventually launched in 2018 boasting
more accurate and nuanced assessments of
players abilities and that's the one
that RI are interested in League of
Legends currently uses a modified
version of chess's Elo system that's
tailored to accommodate a team-based
MOBA game while the intricate details of
this system aren't publicly known it
primarily uses the outcome of a game to
determine whether a player gains or
loses rating how much they gain or lose
is determined by their matchmaking
rating or MMR a hidden score that
represents the player skill level
winning against opponents with a higher
MMR or going on Long win streaks
increases the rating of player gains as
the system tries to more accurately
place them on the rank ladder but a key
area where true skill two differs is
that it can also take into account a
broader range of metrics in order to
determine how much a players rating
should increase or decrease in games
that use true skill 2 the system might
also look at a player's KDA their role
in the game or the relative experience
of the players they went up against it
then uses those metrics to calculate a
fair assessment of the players
contribution to the game in practice a
player might lose a game but because
they had a good KDA they won't lose as
much rating as their teammate that
absolutely fed their face off different
games might use different metrics KDA
might be a good one to use for FPS games
but there is a fairly strong correlation
between a good KDA and a player's
contribution to their team but that's
not necessarily the case with a game
like League you don't have to look much
further than the bouns to see how a
terrible KDA can be irrelevant if you
understand the core of objective of
League of Legends destroy the enemy
Nexus by any means necessary Riot could
look at other metrics to help them here
such as objective control kill
participation endgame damage skill shot
hit rate maybe a complex combination of
a bunch of things in any case it's not
like Riot would share the secret metric
formula with the player base for fear
that players would start playing the
game for those specific metrics why make
a risky play if KDA matters so much more
why sacrifice your life stopping enemy
back so your team can push why let your
teammate have that juicy wave when you
can Farm it to inflate your CS score and
protect your rating at the end of the
game you can see how this might quickly
result in people just gaming the system
instead of you know actually playing the
game and this image of a boring
hellscape where people only play for KDA
has got a lot of people worked up some
have tried to quell the concerns by
suggesting that players protecting their
KDA and farming well already correlates
with more wins so it's not like anyone
would be gaming the system in a way that
goes against League's Core Design but
there's been an outpouring from those
who think the only thing that should
matter is whether a player wins or loses
and see true skill 2 as just a way to
soften the blow for players who played
well on a losing team but all of those
critics may have gotten ahead of
themselves here ryer Barack Pro laid out
the definitions of different rating
systems on Reddit including true skill
adding nothing about true skill to
implies that we must use or wait any
additional factors outside of a win or
loss that said we are always looking to
improve our accuracy and if some factor
or another was highly predictive we
would experiment with it he also said
that using things like KDA as a metric
were not in any way planned but that
they could still do it if it made sense
down the line what he's alluding to here
is that although true skill 2 has been
used in other games to weigh up
different metrics when assessing a
player's performance that's not
necessarily what Riot would use it for
with League true skill 2 can help in
other ways they may use it to
dynamically adjust a player's skill
rating after each match based on the
system certainty of their skill the
Microsoft paper I mentioned earlier goes
into the real nitty-gritty of the
uncertainty principle but here's the
gist as a player plays more games the
system can become more confident of
their skill level by looking at their
consistency number of games played and
level of competition faced a player with
high certainty may experience bigger
swings in their rating gains or losses
as the system tries to figure out their
true skill level the goal would be to
lower their skill uncertainty which
would in turn indicate a more reliable
skill rating essentially true skill 2's
aim is to reduce the number of games
required to identify a player's true
skill this could help create a more
flexible and adaptive system that can
more accurately respond to Smurfs or
trolls as well as players that are
rapidly improving or losing their Edge
and all of that could be achieved by
true skill 2 without taking into account
other metrics like KDA or creep score or
any of the other things people have been
panicking about ryant iscar the writer
who initially shared the news about true
skill 2 took the Reddit yesterday to
quell concerns they said they love that
people are talking about true skill but
wanted to remind everyone they're still
unsure if they'll integrate it into
league and any work to do so has not yet
started they also said that if they did
start it's possible they'd run into a
number number of issues with it but that
their team will give an update on how
it's going later this year so here's the
deal Riot are looking to overhaul the
rank system they're going to be bringing
in a temporary inhouse system in the
near future and then possibly true skill
2 at a later date but even if they do
they may not use lots of different
metrics like KDA to determine rating
gains and losses in ranked they may
simply use it to create a more adaptive
responsive and ultimately fairer rank
system and even if they do take other
metrics into account I wouldn't worry
about it becoming the league of KDA
quite yet because you know that would
require people to actually get good yeah
it is it is funny that that that people
are like oh they're going to start
people are going to start playing for
KDA they they'll just suddenly start
getting loads of kills and not dying I'm
like you know how hard that is for most
people most people can't do that right
now oh now KDA matters okay now I'll
start getting loads of kills and stop
dying okay now I will